[Music]
what's going on guys welcome back to the
channel
today i have this 2014 it's a
chevy chevrolet silverado and we're
gonna program
a new ignition key fob for this truck as
you can see
it's new it's not programmed
and as you can see i have the
information right here already
2014. okay we're gonna go to diagnostics
i'm gonna read the p number
and we access accept the terms
press okay
[Music]
press yes and we see this is a
5.3 liter and this is gonna be a
four wheel drive with uh transfer case
to speed
um this transfer kit to speed
i'm gonna go to hot functions
then uh this is a tool so
add space no navigation
we're gonna select immobilizer and keys
and add replace flops as you can see
we're gonna we can program a maximum of
eight volts so we're gonna check pop one
and it says there's this procedure is
only applicable
it only applies to vehicles without rpo
ath
because with ath need to be programmed
this procedure will replace
an earlier learned key fob with a
replacement key fob
set it in learn more by selecting learn
and then it's gonna it says select
default to be added
press and hold the unlock and lock
buttons at the same time
and the key fob will be added
successfully
for the show so we're going to repeat
this we're going to press ok
and it says erase keyfob 1 and command
it
then we're going to press learn
we see remote learning and then we're
gonna hold and press the two buttons
together
until we hear the peep and as you can
see it says
learn so we just
put escape and
we exit everything we're gonna close
the key and now we're gonna select to
see if it's
programmed as you can see it's already
programmed
it's ready now we're gonna check the
remote start
as you can see the remote start works
just fine for this
open the uh switch
[Music]
and we see that we have lights
so this is how you program the key fob
for a 2014 chevy silverado
and i hope you like the video guys
please if you haven't subscribed to the
channel
subscribe hit the like button and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
bye
you